[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
brain fart moment but we have aj back
hey what's up
everyone welcome thank you thank you
thank you for the theme is that the
theme song for you i
i have a customized one every single
time if you hear that like if you hear
music can
you can you already know the notes um i
mean i know like
the notes in in a perceived scale but i
don't know exactly i don't suppose lying
he already hears the notes and he could
probably already harmonize do it
yeah he already made a whole song with
lyrics can i can i can i tell you a
secret
yeah it's got it's gonna be public now
but
i wanted in in real life i want to be a
musician
but i'm shy what do you know what shy
means i don't think you know which i
mean i am
about music oh because it's like so
close to your soul
yeah because like it's too vulnerable oh
yeah it's like
i don't know you're exposing your heart
when you tell me to sing i get kind of
like this but then everything else it's
fine you know like
all [ __ ] in the streets and whatever
[Laughter]
but seeing no way jose when it comes to
music i always wanted to be
a big music star and i couldn't so i
just became a funny guy
yeah but you have music what'd you do
huh what kind of music would you do all
kinds
everywhere i would explore i want to
create my own genre that's
yeah i'm very creative i mean knowing
your background now that makes sense
how you're traumatized with music when
you're a little kid but you have a
korean barbecue song
that we made yeah yeah we made a lot of
fun music dude dusky hunters was [ __ ]
that's true pdm i wanted to yeah i want
to do an acoustic album i want to do
reggae album
um oh my god please do like a hawaiian
one like the hawaiian music that you
like to listen to yeah
did you like jawayan joe wine but i
don't know about i'll sing on it maybe
i'll
i'll produce it and someone else will
sing on it that sounds cool
yeah but maybe i'll say maybe i'll debut
that way i don't know
i just want to see if we can work on
something you know oh
only yeah do you know any singers i'm
i'm down man
he's already hiding something we we were
um
gonna create a vietnamese funk band yes
and who's weak like you two oh and
whoever else wants to join it was called
the uncles and the refugees
you replayed you tell me about this
didn't he play with us
we did perform as the uncles and
referees yes you have right
that was one of the shows yeah that was
one of the shows that we played together
yeah we had a drummer
it was like a doo-wop song huh yeah dude
i totally remember this
that was the show that kabaddar was part
of too was that yeah that was the one
was it outdoors or was it was it in
chino it was in the auditorium like a
smaller one oh okay
felt like a cafeteria almost i'm
surprised you're not you're pursuing
that right now because like
lately you've just been doing what joe
wants to do and taking pictures of your
bare ass on it
doesn't seem like anything's really
holding you back you know what it is
it's all of these bucket list things
that i've been wanting to do
and me and darian like darian's our
friend he's a photographer and he just
lives
life taking pictures of butts a picture
at a time
okay like beautiful gorgeous very very
beautiful like that's his profession
right
poor guy man we need to help him and
then he was like joe i want to do
like comedy one with you where like i
have one of my models and then like you
pan over and it's you
and i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah we're gonna do
this right and then
we we've probably been talking about it
for like a couple of years already just
laughing oh come on
yeah and then we just never every time
we meet we're always talking about like
yeah we got to do one right and then
finally so we went camping and then he's
like joe
are you ready and i'm like oh i got my
ball ready
i pulled my underwear up like a thong i
well i dropped my clothes off first i
was and i pulled it up and i'm like i'm
i'm [ __ ] ready dude like he was like
go over there right now
his models over there like on on the on
a rock i [ __ ] ran
barefoot in the [ __ ] forest and i was
like wait for me
and i got up next to her [ __ ] god in
doggy style positions
and we just thought it's that you were
on all fours yeah nice
it's a beautiful picture you should see
it it's like the most high quality
picture of me in a underwear thong no
and i had to message him i was like how
dare you not give a trigger warning i
didn't
know the girl messed it up right she was
so gross
she was she [ __ ] it all up are you
gonna pursue a modeling career now
i think i might really open up only fans
and i think you would kill it and play
music on there
maybe oh my god i want to be fun i would
actually subscribe to yours because i
don't know what to expect
like i don't know what the day is going
to bring you should do it i think i
might do it but yeah
i don't know what else is on your bucket
list uh what have you done that was
already on your list
okay so this week has been pretty crazy
because
you know how i always wanted to farm
right yeah which one
what kind of farm cane farm or like
animal farms i would i want
i specifically want a sugar cane farm
but like i like a tropical fruit farm is
like the goals that me and my cousin's
going to build
but um i recently got in partnership
with a with the shiitake mushroom farm
and so um this guy's already a partner
to our our restaurant group
he's he's uh in charge of opening up uh
junebe
our our matcha tea uh franchise out in
the east coast
and we became pretty cool friends and he
got his uh
i guess wealth or business first from uh
rescuing his dad from his uh uh mushroom
farm so he grew up on his mushroom farm
his dad
was kind of like just all over the place
and then he came in with his banking
background and just like
shot it off the roof like it's in whole
foods and all this stuff right so then
me and him he was like
oh i'm trying to figure out a way to
like do this
and and and sell it directly to the
public and then we
came up with the idea of you know how
like the chia pet right everyone can
grow something at home and
it was pretty fun that the whole family
can do yeah so we're developing these
mushroom kits
so long story short he wants to expand
into the west coast because he's already
in tofus and all that in the east coast
so this week he came and visited we went
to go check out all these different
farms
so i was like bro can i have a mud hut
on the farm
and he's like yeah you could have a mud
mud hut and my other friend's like can i
build a tree house on your farm
and he's like yeah and we're like can we
create a bike park
on the farm it's like we don't even want
to fight mostly just a playground
it's a playground dude so yeah
there's a property now with like a home
and two kind of ranch houses things
that is in the central coast so it's
perfect weather man we went out there
it's by like pismo beach yeah
it's [ __ ] beautiful man it's it's
imagine like farmland but like
right next to the ocean yo you should
pitch that mushroom kit to shark tank or
something like that man
we don't need their money oops
yeah maybe i shouldn't neighborhood not
even money connections i know you're
right you're right you're right you know
what i mean
mark cuban bro cuban was part of it you
can just drop his name
oh [ __ ] somebody sent this to mark cuban
i just want to see you on tv
on that i know work on your pitch and
then send it okay i'm gonna walk in in
the mushroom outfit
currently his pitches started with uh i
don't need his money
yeah he's gonna pull out that clip
so you know i'm gonna get my mud hut
built i'm a yeah it's just crazy so
you're going to build it yourself oh you
know i am ah
can i help you you could just get a
really like terrible home if you didn't
build himself
yeah i think i like that idea if we get
it on man like
everyone's got to come and camp there
yeah yeah ride bikes
hell yeah dude yeah so life's been just
kind of like
i've been wanting to do a lot of things
finally go camping finally do all of
these things right and
quarantine kind of turned out to be this
thing where
i realized that i didn't have to retire
or make more or do anything to live the
life that i want right now
hell yeah that's great it reminds me how
have you been spending your quarantine
um i mean like this whole pandemic time
yeah it's been kind of it's been
actually a little more busy when it
comes to like projects and stuff i'm
being asked like
by theaters and i've been doing a lot of
stuff in musical theater lately
um so i've been being asked by these
actual theaters who are like trying to
go to virtual programming you know to
like help edit their stuff or run their
live streams
like they're doing cats but online i
mean
essentially that's probably what they
want to do they want to eventually do
that
but right now we're just doing like
cabarets which is just like solo acts
and stuff or
you know for their galas that they
usually have every year they put the
programming virtually
but i've been helping because i've been
like an actor or a music director in
their company
um so they're asking me to do things
that i by trade
i'm not an editor but i can edit right
like by trade i'm not like a live stream
director but
i can do it so i end up like doing it
music editor or video editor
video editing and and music editing
which is like
it's fine because i want to help them
out but i'm like lowballing myself when
it comes to my time that i'm spending
and the money that i am receiving or not
receiving right for
this the amount of time yeah for the
amount of time that i'm doing so
lately i'm just going through the think
of it i've said yes to so many things
and um i've ended up being a little more
busy
in quarantine wow then not because also
i mean you all know like the college
shows uh you know they help
financially of course right and uh since
they got cancelled or whatever
um i think i'm doing more work
now to kind of compensate yeah yeah
seeing obviously how to adjust
yeah and so actually mentally it's been
i mean you asked like how it's been
going quarantine and we all have that
answer on the phone we're like yeah you
know relatively well blah blah blah
but now i'm like actually you wanna go
camping just like
speak out say it out just like damn it's
actually
camping a lot it's actually a lot i
think mentally
even trying to answer that question it's
like there's so much freaking going on
in my head
you know i wish i could just like have
the summer off and go camping let's do
it dude
i mean you know i i'd love to just do
that and it does it doesn't uh
necessarily help
uh not help in a bad way but my
girlfriend's working from home
she works at 9 00 a.m every day to 6 p.m
you know so
i wake up at that time as well you know
and she's working from home she's in my
same studio so
we are kind of in like work mode
but it's fun i mean it's hard to
complain i've heard that a lot though
like a lot of couples
have to adjust to like living or just
sharing the same space
but like in a work mind you know what i
mean which is so different because you
share the same space as a couple
and that's just a whole different vibe
but then as soon as you bring in work
it's like shut the [ __ ] up i'm in a
meeting or like
we have to schedule when our meetings
are yeah that's the crazy thing is like
i have to schedule if i'm able to be
listening to monitors or just on
headphones
based on her meetings because we're in
that same room it works out fine because
we tell each other in advance
but i'm also not used to like planning
things out all the time she's very
organized you're not used to planning
creativity but now you have to
yes be creative at 3 30. it's hard yeah
that's so true
i just usually will wait for her to get
off at six o'clock
and then i'll um that's when i'll plan
to be
you know you have to plan around lunch
too much planning
it's too exciting for lunch though like
you don't have time to cook
so right right right so that's when you
hit up our sponsor postmates
yep that's right because um
you know i've been kind of using
postmates like whenever i'm busy
i i just moved and um
you know when you're moving and you got
a plan you just got no time for nothing
thank goodness there's something like
postmates because uh i was really hungry
and i was craving some
chicken and waffles and i was like i
need to plan this out
right because i only have a certain
period
where i can work out and i didn't tell
you guys this but i had to move a
two-bedroom house
all into a studio in one day wow well i
was like all right so what am i gonna do
i'm gonna call pulse mates and then post
mates
hooked me up with some chicken and
waffles right after my workout i got to
eat
and i got to finish everything on time
it was so amazing
that's why for efficiency's sake i
always
use the postmates and for a limited time
offer for our listeners only
postmates is giving you guys a hundred
dollars of free
delivery credit for your first seven
days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use the code off
the record
that's off the record for 100 of free
delivery credit with no minimum purchase
for
seven days use the code off the record
thank you post mates thank you very much
thank you postmates yeah it's been
really difficult
sharing the space i know i could i could
relate because even though like with
casey and i we have always
worked from home mainly unless we have
to come in here and then film
but during quarantine though it is like
a different adjustment because
even though we are used to working at
home together there
most of the day will be taken up by us
going out and doing errands or whatever
and now that we have to
maintain and stay at home it's just like
oh man yeah
you end up spending hair way more time
together
than like normal couples do in a couple
years
you know what i mean but i think that
does that cause fights and stuff or not
um i can't even really he's like
how do i answer no i can't remember like
a huge huge fight i remember just like
little things like that we just need to
get used to and
and plan around and schedule you don't
take me for the fighting type
well thank you take me for the uh uh
i'll understand or i'll
i'll i'll try to bend for you type you
know i've learned i've learned a lot in
the last couple years
we had um some problems in the first
couple years because i have
an ex of like seven years you know so
that
that emotionally so she's still finding
her underwear like in random places
yeah my mom's house um she's like
oh what the hell oh sorry that was 2013
years come on imagine how many panties
all over the place
okay maybe not like panties but but like
emotional connections with emotionally
emotional people like that
emotional panties that you find i like
that
around the house or in relation uh in
friendships and relationships with your
family and stuff
that you still find in the first couple
years yeah it's it's caused some fights
for sure but i'm glad that we went
through that so she's coming into your
space
or like how is that or is not is it her
for work from home
no no i mean like that whole emotional
panties things like like
it's because you were with someone for
so long or like because i was with
someone for so long that they're so
interwoven and connected with my family
also she's still around
uh not anymore uh she moved to texas
um somewhere but there's just residuals
like when i go to her brother's house
like i see like pictures of all of her
other two oh still there
yeah 200 yeah you know i got around in
the group photos yeah but it doesn't
bother me
but i get it like there's there's a lot
of little emotional panties all over the
place emotional pain
there's only one picture but i feel you
though that one picture
though there was actually a photo as
well that we thought about as well like
a
physical tangible photo um and and
i'm not blaming her at all like i'm not
saying that maybe you should yeah
you know what i would do is i'll be like
oh so you want to keep pictures of your
ex
in the house why don't you suck on my
dick and we'll bring this picture right
here
they can [ __ ] watch you're twisted i
like you why is that bad
well i mean i mean what a threat
it is exciting you look at the picture
right when you look at it you go
do you go like oh i can't believe
like how do you have past like jealousy
that's past jealousy yeah it's like you
are the better
that's why she's with you and not or
she's or whatever is there with you
not them right so it's like you missed
out but thank you for making her better
for me
you know what i mean like easier said
than done it is but i'm heartless bro
i it's i can't even i
and then just play some nasty keys for
her you [ __ ]
all the black keys
[Applause]
[ __ ] you it is easy to you know emote
with music yeah
express it's just a feeling honestly i
feel like
musicians or any artists um they
have a constructive way of expressing
how
like they have an outlet yeah whereas
like i noticed that if
sometimes i don't creatively express i
it's almost like having a ball full of
[ __ ] just stuck
yeah and you gotta bust that
[ __ ] where is it stuck that you
feel it
in my scrotum soul oh okay stuck in your
throat or something
it just looks like you gotta get
something out right
and or something it's just something's
not right
and then you go and you're like you feel
better
all right cool yeah yeah i mean i'm i'm
grateful too that my
um alyssa also is um is a singer
do you guys fight through song we fight
through song it's like a musical
yeah like a [ __ ] music oh yeah what
are you doing to me
our life is like a musical honestly um
but we've been making tick tocks
together i love this music video one way
you just start playing piano from the
work from home off
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that started i
love that
um on tick tock since that tick tock
blew up of her singing reflection
now we're doing covers from our desks so
we
just edit the angles together and stuff
and it's been
really fun for us like a little project
we release one every day
you know what i mean mostly disney songs
and it's fun and it brings us closer
uh musically and that's so cute
that is that is hella cute that you have
a thing like a special activity
and you're both skilled at it true yeah
we're lucky for sure you guys can like
harmonize like she could sing in the
shower and you could probably just jump
in and harmonize and she's a great
harmonizer i think
like a lot of singers take that skill
for granted you know what i mean and
a lot of singers who are artists can't
even do that on the fly
harmonizing is like when you're not
using words kind of thing
there's like one lead is like there's
like one key and then they come in with
a key that matches but it's not the
right you see that easier this is almost
another note now
when the two notes come together think
of like a choir and there's people
singing like
four different parts the part that's not
the melody is the harmony
so the part that you know in your mind
you're singing along to a song if
someone's singing on top of that
that's uh just do one right now tell me
that i'll see you i'll sing a song and
then you harmonize to it okay go ahead
well i don't know any songs tell me
what's up just do it just just do it no
just do it no
just do it now harmonize to this okay
mary had
a little laugh mary
five six seven eight mary
had a little laughs are following you
yeah yeah yeah
i'm sorry the camera is gonna catch me
laughing when you ask me about what a
harmony is
uh but i was not trying to be like a
music sure
i think you were no no i completely was
not i'll take it for you
yeah i was yeah but it's like two notes
and it becomes like another note and it
sounds
it sounds all like like rude right right
like living in harmony together not
musically that means
everything's just going right chaos so
it's not the same
it's complementing it exactly yes it's
not the same it complements it got it
yes i understand now i love these oh
that's a good way of putting it
yeah it's a support it's a support
supporting melody
support melody like a support brawl
i miss bone thugs and harmony me too
boom boom boom boom
do